What have you got for us today, Eitan?
Yeah, so today we're gonna be making dessert pasta.
Now dessert pasta actually dates all the way back
to Italy during the Renaissance.
Pasta was a luxury
and so they paired it with other luxury goods
like sugar and cinnamon.
Dessert pasta was born.
So how do we make it?
So you're just gonna grab yourselves
some little wonton wrappers.
Here, you can grab one from right here.
Thank you, Eitan.
We have wonton wrappers
and we're just gonna take our little egg wash.
Oh, I think I might be doing it wrong.
I think one...oh, your egg wash is right here.
Oh, I found it.
Oh, I have a whole set over here, Eitan.
So, take your egg wash and you're basically
just going to brush lightly
the outside of the wonton wrapper.
Then just spoon in about a teaspoon worth
of chocolate hazelnut spread.
Is that on side on the egg wash side?
Yeah, you can just put it right in there, yes.
How about this, baby.
Yes, then take your fingers
and just seal it up, just like that.
Give it a little pinch, pinch, pinch.
And then, as you can see in front of us,
we already have them made.
Eitan, I'm oozing out the sides.
Oh man, oh God, Oh.
(Drew and audience laugh)
That looks like you may have put a table spoon.
What was I supposed to put?
Teaspoon.
Oh.
We have these ones that are pretty far...
I don't know if that's safe to fry, not gonna lie.
(all laugh)
To be totally honest.
I kind of wanna test it.
Yeah, so we have oil now,
preheated to about 350 degrees Fahrenheit.
So, add this into the oil,
and those are just going to sizzle up and crisp up,
get golden brown on the outside.
Now the chocolate hazelnut spread on the inside
is just gonna kind of melt and get like gooey and melty.
And it just results in a delicious little fried treat.
It's kind of like a little donut meets a dumpling
meets pasta meets chocolate.
Mine's looking good.
It's getting really nice and crispy, slightly golden.
Yeah, those are ready.
Oh, they are?
Yeah, those are ready to go.
Oh good. Look, watch, I'll just do this and voila.
Dun da da dun.
(crowd cheers and claps)
There you go.
Oh, these are just demi loons of perfection, Eitan.
Now, ready for it?
We're gonna make it rain with powdered sugar.
Make it rain.
Maybe, get all of it all over.
(crowd cheers and claps)
Make it rain.
I made it rain.
Yes, and now shall we give it a try?
Cheers, love you.
Cheers, cheers.
Ooh, that's hot.
Oh my God.
What?
It's so good.
(crowd cheers and claps)
Mm. Mmm-mm.
This is good.
Yeah.
Eitan, I love this recipe.
Thank you for always bringing
such inventive, amazing things.
If you're not already following Eitan,
which I'm sure you are,
please check out his Instagram and TikTok.
I learn more... I'm always bugging you.
Like, I learn so much through your content.
You are so amazing, you have a brand new book.
I'm so happy for you.
It is just a joy to ride alongside...
Yes, thank you.
And thank you again for blurbing the book.
It comes out May 3rd.
All right, Eitan, I love you.
Thank you, this is so beautiful.
Go to the drewbarrymoreshow.com to get the full recipe
and make it for yourself, and we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)